la gestion des populations aujourd'hui
est faite par louer quoique l'office
national de la biodiversité
les populations d'animaux par territoire
ils font des contrôles de nuit chacun et
on peut y assister qui calcule les le
grandissement des populations est
établie par rapport à ça des plans de
chasse les chasseurs ne sont pas libres
de tuer tout ce qu'ils veulent ce n'est
absolument pas vrai je vais qua non de
chasse quel droit tu fais quoi mais y'a
plein d'animaux qui sont chassés il y
avait meilleur de ce qu'on appelle de
gros gibier c'est à dire cerfs sangliers
et chevreuils va y avoir des oiseaux va
y avoir de rien alors s'il ya une chose
qui a chassé toutes les semaines ou mois
chasse toutes les semaines alors ma
chasse particulièrement à court donc
moi c'est une chose que j'apprécie
particulièrement sa cour
un débat dessus mais c'est qui ce fait
c'est la chasse qui est pour moi la plus
naturelle qui soit parce qu'on va venir
confronter animal sauvage à des chiens
les chiens qui sont des compacts et les
lames est en fac talent et à l'endurance
ou mettez un avantage considérable c'est
qu'on vient
stimuler un animal sauvage dans son
environnement il le connaît
le débat et pas sur la chasse à courre
fondamental c'est que un animal mais je
vais très chassard des chiens les chiens
on va avoir dix minutes un quart d'heure
20 25 minutes de retard un cerf un
sanglier un chauffeur et à prendre 25
ans on a fait un parcours va faire des
ruses et nous en connaissons nos chiens
on va suivre cette piste pour la
remontée on n'est pas du tout sur une
chasse pour moi que c'est pas barbare
mais ce que l'on joue dans les règles de
l'animal sauvage il a toutes les
qualités peut pas déjà lé vainqueur
vincent qui
permet d'aller défendre non mais vous
dire qu'à faire tout le temps c'est
complètement faux on est la chasse qui
prélève le moins par rapport aux gens
des choses qu'on organise trois chances
sur quatre ne prend pas on ne prend pas
moi je fais 50 chasse par an je prends
entre sept et huit animaux par an sur
cinq ans de chasse est en revanche ah
oui les animaux c'est beaucoup moins si
je tombe sur
les animaux comprend effectivement l'an
dernier n'avait donc été blessées qui
avaient été blessés par des bagnoles
voit les chiens tombe dessus et le
prélèvement ça c'est la loi de la nature
mathieu la nature n'ont alors pas ce que
vous avez entendu la west on parle de
tout
exploration pas si on parle de tout la
chasse normal moi un animal il est dans
son livre ici ses billes dans son
élément tout d'un coup ils s'envolent
qui va être tué quelques secondes avant
je savais pas je déteste me répéter mais
ça me choque moins la chasse à courre
oui ça c'est horrible cette jeune fille
souffrait déjà une heure deux ans oui
j'en ai vu et on a vu cet hommage à deux
oeuvres vous avez déjà suivi une chasse
à courre à mais jamais j'irai messieurs
c'est horrible c'est
vraiment le jeu des humains vous allez
acheter à la marche était le juge si le
jeu des humains contraints déjà la
planoise et horizons chasse pas à cheval
on chasse à pied c'est le lièvre
l'animal la même chose voilà c'est pour
vous amuser vous êtes vous êtes à 20 da
rien animatrice pour vous amuser c'est
une distraction élections ne s'est pas
créé les questions de savoir ce qui moi
me plaisait en chasse à courre je me
suis posé la question oui quel crime
mais moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
insert il a des qualités moi je suis
particulièrement le ser - chasse au cerf
et le sanglier et le cerf y ait des
qualités qui sont incroyables
effectivement on peut le voir en forêt
mais quand ils le jeu quand on le chasse
il va avoir des russes qui sont
phénoménales qui va aller se mélanger
avec d'autres il va faire des boucs seul
et même pour en mêlée ses voix on va
observer les chinois ont fait un jeu que
lui j'ai fait un jeu que moi j'ai choisi
pas du tout c'est la loi de la serre
j'avais laissé ma course sur le sert
effectivement si abandonnions la trappe
nous même quand il passe une année où on
le tire au monde et il passe une allée
se serait pas naturelle je suis d'accord
mais la chasse à courre c'est naturel
qu'est ce qui a vraiment qu'avec la
meute qui l'utilisent suis en une chance
vous aurez conduite raison d'en parler
comme l abattoir le voyage de ces
animaux vous vous rendez sur
jarrett chasse à courre je déteste
shadow leur voie d'échangé c'est
horrible c'est une distraction comme ça
de bourgeois le dimanche on sait
aujourd'hui avec l'intelligence animale
que l'animal effectivement un stress qui
comprend ce qui se passe vous dites mais
c'est un jeu c'est un jeu qui joue
j'avais choisi pas lui le cerf il est
pas du tout choisi de mourir 2 ou de
joie et vous ce jour mais alors pas du
tout chez lui fait jurer de toutes les
lois de la nature en afrique on essaie
pas de la lèze dur d'aller chasser un
cerf du dimanche par les deux pas des
champs qui le chassent 6 1 les chats qui
le chassent s'il dans les soutes
présenté le dimanche mais les chiens qui
le cherche il ya une loi qui est passé
on a arrêté c'est tout à fait normal
pourchasse pas dans les lotissements il
est passé
de chiens dans un lotissement qui ont
éventré de chat donc c'est l'entrée de
chats et des chiens qui attrapent des
chats y en a partout dans la journée ils
voient les retards des émissions
sécurité et vous oubliez quand même la
question des élevages d'animaux parce
que ce qu'on dit pas les matières de
chez les intéressés qui à 30 millions
d'années - qui sont élevées pour être
lâché et qui sont qui servent de cibles
vivantes alors
scandale est très intéressant
aujourd'hui en france y'a pas d'élevage
de grand gibier cerf sanglier il ya des
bouts mais c'est souvent bien des
virages de sangin il ya d élevage de
sangliers pour faire du pâté et cerner
note il ya des lâchés
musical n est pas en france maintenant
sur le petit gibier effectivement il ya
une grande partie du petit gibier qui a
chassé en france 20 millions arrivé non
mais déjà vous sortez de chez différents
il ya trop les animaux les petits
gibiers sont lâchés à trois périodes de
l'année il y en a deux que je trouve
intéressante ces dépôts des lâchers de
repeuplement à la fin de la saison de
chasse ou moment de la reproduction sur
les perdrix et faisans ça c'est
intéressant pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a une agriculture
intensive qui utilisent des produits
chimiques qui détruit ces espèces là on
a décidé de rayer les aident nos cartes
et on a fait des cultures à perte de vue
qui font qu'on est ces animaux n'ont
plus de quoi se protéger en mer et donc
effectivement ces populations de autant
de perdus ont diminué et de faire du
gras que battu intérêts sont maintenant
moi je suis d'accord avec vous je suis
contre totalement le lâcher la veille
pour aller les flinguer lendemain sache
que c'est une aberration mais je suis
sûr que ça disparaîtra dans les années à
venir puisque sa noble c'est quoi le
jeune homme étudie le mathieu mathieu
c'est quoi le quine de la chasse en fait
c'est quoi le alors vous manger la
viande non non non non pas de la poésie
ravoux le dimanche devenir
meilleur marché comme acquis aujourd'hui
enfoncé à 98 profond de la population
qui mangent de la viande ça a dû faire
et quoi
c'est très bon train aujourd'hui 98 %
des gens ne mangent de la viande ils
viennent de deux sources différentes il
yad'un côté de l'élevage alors il ya
plein de types d'élevage ainsi autant de
types d'élevage que deux campagnes en
france et ils peuvent venir de la chasse
moi qui mangent de la viande je me dis
qu'elle est chassé un animal sauvage de
le tuer de le manger de cuisine et de le
manger parce que je cuisine aussi le
curé de le manger ça a du sens déjà je
me cache pas derrière un abattoir
anondin connurent je me dis ah non moi
je veux pas voir l'animal un animal dans
la nord jeu juste avoir une barquette
charest devant moi où je cuisine non non
l'avantagé la chasse et comment vous
assumez suite mathieu 2